en alberta la vague orange du printemps
dernier
a considérablement rajeuni l'assemblée
provinciale comme l'a constaté laurent
pirot et changement de génération met
parfois au jour de vieux archaïsme au
chapitre de l'égalité hommes femmes
la député de calgary stéphanie mclean
doit accoucher en février ce sera son
premier enfant
la première fois aussi qu'une députée
deviendra maman pendant son mandat est
ici rien n'est prévu aucun congé pour
lui permettre de se remettre de
l'accouchement la règle sur
l'absentéisme c'est que si elle
s'absente plus de dix jours
elle devrait être sanctionné et le chêne
neuf lits y voit un archaïsme
rochelle notre ligue a aussi préparé un
cadeau pour le futur bébé avec un
message de jack layton au delà de cette
question du congé maternité y en a
beaucoup d'autres
stéphanie mclean ne sera pas la seule la
seule élue à voir des jeunes enfants
parmi les questions sur la table on
parle d'un service de garde adaptés aux
horaires des députés leurs employés et
puis on parle aussi de séances
différentes le matin pour éviter que les
débats se prolongent tard le soir
ça permettrait aux députés d'avoir des
horaires plus nombre